we've done adults decide
teenagers decide what else have we done
millennials decide millennials
and they've all failed miserably
can seniors pull through kane oh i i'm
excited for this one because i have a
lot of hope i'm all about some wholesome
stuff and there's nothing more wholesome
than some old people arguing about don't
make money
don't look at the dislike part stop
video
no legs gang merch now's your last
chance
to get the limited edition of the no
legs gang pewdiepie
exterior merch people are real mad about
it
i don't care i wear it anyway with pride
we also got this sick figurine look at
the damn look at the details of that
thing huh
you want this they don't make figurines
like these anymore
that's actually sick i never seen it so
up close before
what do you say shake on it done deal
check the link in the description
for real it's a really cool collab
support me support one of the greatest
indie games of all time
and if you get one of these bad boys
shake on it
you also get stickers you have to also
sign up for the newsletter to get the
stickers but
free stickers shake on it okay all right
i get you're a tough cookie you're a
tough sell
how about this by ordering the t-shirt
by ordering whatever
you get 15 off the terraria online store
that's pretty cool
for life for life this is an investment
no legs gangs
show support show love all the best
that's it
on with the video come on
you gotta buy fur all right look these
are gonna be nice old people grandma
mom's gonna get on there and be like oh
honey you need that thousand dollars for
you
your dentures oh yeah and they're gonna
be like that's right and
first round they're gonna figure it out
guaranteed guaranteed yeah i'm really
curious what
seniors priorities are with money right
what do they want to
do with it give it to their kids i guess
yeah exactly that's what they do with
money
i'll accept that at least but i'm
curious if there's something else all
right let's watch
i thought i was going to come here and
there will be people representing other
charities and i'm the only one
and everybody else has a personal reason
i apologize wait they vote they voted
out the charity guy right away
on the chair every time they vote at the
charity guys
the video just started he's already on
the chair okay
i think this is a little snippet of
what's to come coming out but i'm not
stepping out
because i believe in this oh seniors
there's no hope is it
[Music]
there's nothing sadder to me than like
bitter old people because it's like [ __ ]
you failed your entire life
and you got no time left bro maybe
they're just bitter maybe maybe they're
better because they're just so
successful and tired of all these
youngins that they can't pay their rent
you know okay
yeah that's right yeah this poor [ __ ]
millennial said argue about a thousand
dollars how could they
do you guys know each other no no no we
don't
what do you guys all have in common
we're seniors yes
who here is the oldest 73. anybody got
him beat
87 oh oh yeah
who's the youngest so you can still flex
about your age when you're old that's
good to know
well i'm 87. i hear when you get older
like you start to like regress right you
kind of like go back in life so
back to that stage like oh yeah well i'm
older than you
i can also run faster than you my
grandma does that and it's really sweet
actually she's like all these other
old people they're so slow i'm so fat
really like dang grandma get him
yeah i'm like yeah hell yeah it's kind
of sweet i don't know
probably me i'm 41.
oh really sure come
on you guys all have to decide who
leaves with a thousand dollars
there's gonna be four rounds where you
will get
a chance to eliminate one person when
we're down to the final three people
those three people have to decide on one
person to leave with a thousand
or they can just split it magically and
even though it's against the rules
say that every single time it's never
going to happen except for that last
time when it did happen at the end
hang on yeah they can't just change
their rules i don't believe anything
you're gonna pay one person and it's
gonna be a direct deposit
so you'd have to trust that person that
you don't know will probably never see
again is gonna send you your money
oh okay i'm gonna play the game when i
start the first round find out about
each other what do you mean
how else would you do this just sit
still
like no girl i don't want to know you i
don't even want to know you
give me a thousand dollars i don't want
to hit anybody i'll pay you a thousand
dollars not to tell me about you
i had a child pass away last year and
i never got a chance to grieve it i
would just love to go somewhere and
scream
at the top of my lungs where would you
go arizona
who's next we got 15 minutes that's you
okay i want a thousand dollars
to do a program that i'm working on to
house the homeless
i'm on disability i live on 12 000 a
year
i would love to win a thousand dollars
because
my dog bit up my bottom teeth i don't
know what i can't eat the foods i love
like peanuts and cashews and all that
watch them just say just chew from the
sides
just just have your just have your
grandkids come over and chew it for you
it's easy okay get a blender really
yeah you gotta blend their [ __ ]
oh man i feel bad for that okay fair
that's a fair cause i mean he just wants
some teeth in my mouth twelve thousand
dollars a year she lives up there
yeah he has done disability a thousand
dollars a month
look i'm waiting for one of these old
dudes to be like oh you're on disability
yeah your charity were you they were
just giving you money
i'd put a down payment on some new
appliances my name is 12. she needs what
appliances
mm-hmm some nearby sure
get a fridge i mean there's some sick
fridges like have you seen the one with
a double layer
you press a button and then it open it's
a different fridge
what yeah oh ken
did you watch my invention video i
assume you didn't let me show you the
most amazing [ __ ] you've ever seen in
your life i gotta show you is this one
in 480p
no shut up i mean yes they are all
uh it was intentional of course i was
looking up inventions
of uh how can our future be better right
okay this is what i found you can look
the fridge that comes to you oh my god
get that science have solved
pain it's all done look
dude but can this refrigerator go to the
grocery store for me that's why i need
to know
oh oh
man dude if i ever go on these shows i'm
just going to say hey there's this
fridge from panasonic and it [ __ ]
moves
you know watching netflix you know when
you're like your 500th first
episode of one piece hey fridge april
give me a mountain dew then it's like
dude i barely have anything in me i'm so
small
sorry and then you have to get up and go
the store anyway
that's cool though i think it's pretty
neat it don't ruin my hope and dreams
it needs to be like a full-size fridge i
mean like a giant fridge that comes out
i'm sure they can figure out the giant
fridge but it's probably
a safety issue with falling over and
crushing that's not gonna say you're
like still the cat's like bring me a
bring me your beard it comes in just
like falls on you
imagine that going off a light or
something
what a terrible idea but i love it
i love it so much i can't wait for the
future i hope she gets that with a
thousand dollars
back door was kicked in there was a guy
knocking on the front door and i said
i'm not going to answer it because i
know he's going to sell me something
there was another guy at the back door
that started knocking and i walked
around the kitchen and
bam he kicked my door in so i ran after
him
what was that story that there was a guy
knocking on her front door and she went
answer it because it was a salesman
then some other dude knocked on her back
door kicked it in and then ran
no she chased him out she's like
putting my back door i think what are
you actually doing the first time
well i'm deanna and i could mimic many
of these stories
um you can't just throw that in there
i could take all of these stories
all of them applies to me as well
except for the dentures that one's a
little weird i can't do the denture one
i can apply the dog abiding
what a way to start is take some time
for me having my first child at 15 and
having my first grandchild when my sixth
daughter came into play
i haven't been able to be alone and do
me and be me my name is al i live
that's the most vague thing i've ever
heard
she comes up so like aggressive she's
like i could you know i could say all
this crap they're
saying buying refrigerators and teeth
and
i just need some me time and a thousand
dollars
i just need some me time with me and my
thousand dollars just sitting and
chilling man come on just
let's get it right baby manor that's a
retirement community
and i thought i was going to be here to
make a pitch for a charity rather than
for individuals so i'm going to vote
myself
off because i'm the outlier here but i
want to explain why what and that is
that bayview has a foundation
whose purpose is to make sure nobody has
to leave because they run out of money
so what i was going to ask for was a
thousand dollars to be a matching grant
because we're going out for a fundraiser
but i don't want to compete with
personal problems because they're very
powerful
so good luck to you all and i don't want
to be in a position of society who's
getting this money
so i'm voting myself off but but in the
past people have
played the game and for charity but
i don't understand why are the people
that are here for charity well at least
the last
two times been like probably the best
person that actually should have kept
the money
looking like the most sensible people
like you got girl down here in the
middle that's just like i screw
everybody and then
this dude's like hey i feel bad now uh i
thought this here for a different reason
right yeah
yeah i don't know this charity is for
people in need but i mean
i guess everyone here sees themselves as
a charity case so i'm gonna go sit down
at least they didn't vote him off like
we thought
what a silence yes no
they just do you hear them whimper out
of no in between
them to stay
thank you very much oh wow
do you want to convince him to stay play
the game you know everyone had their
pitch
the other guy's for charity too
you come over here and sit on the couch
right here you can say whatever you want
the round is over somebody eliminated
themselves how do you guys feel about
that
didn't expect it at all i thought i was
going to come here and there will be
people representing other charities
and i'm the only one and everybody else
has a personal reason but
yeah i'm here to promote a program for
homelessness that doesn't exist
i applied for but i'm not stepping out
because i believe in this
but he's personally involved in doing it
which is a much different from where i
am i didn't start it and it
didn't go on without me yours can't go
on without you
so what i want to do is a permanent
house
that the taxpayers have to pay for that
is a little more expensive than a tent
where you can lock your stuff up
and you can be safe and instead of the
state spending
five hundred thousand dollars for every
homeless person they spend
much less than that doesn't seem like a
bad idea at least i don't know
yeah just uh trying to save a little bit
of money as an engineer you know throw
that in there
doing taxes so you know you know they're
already like my taxes
okay and i do project management and
that kind of things and i think i can do
it personally
i feel that that would be just a black
hole
as a taxpayer i see a lot you were right
you were right
just a nip i think donating that would
be
a more positive thing than trying to
create something new
it would be better for you to just give
away the money to a charity instead of
trying to do something good with it
yourself
yeah what i don't know if this is a
thing like where i
where i live there's a lot of really old
people that just like
really hate paying taxes and the
thought of somebody that is in need
getting help with their tax money i
don't know what the problem is like they
would get the money they'll be like oh
my god they're on disability they just
don't want to work and they just want to
get my
money back i'm just like all right dude
but i don't know if that's something
else where your taxes go to
the people in need are very small
percentage
of that all right especially in america
it's like oh god damn we gotta keep that
military budget up
yeah yeah have you looked at the tax
payer budget for like a second and
have you looked realized that projecting
have you looked at our government
spending budget
probably not because i don't think it
exists
[Laughter]
over here oh boy
yeah can we not play it this way what do
you want to do
what do you mean she's so pessimistic
she's so mad but like
has nothing to offer to the conversation
[Laughter]
that'd be down or in the middle should
we all talk about our experience now
no should the charity guy stay
no no because honestly i i could pick
every one of these and say i've gone
through it and so i need it for that but
you know and then those
some of those things bring up other
things and it makes the game not a game
anymore so
if we're going to play a game let's play
a game yeah we're going to play rock
paper scissors
i mean what are we going to do i hear
two people saying i need space for me
i'm also hearing i need teeth and on the
spectrum here
teeth seem to be the most fundamental
yeah
i agree so we could go that way who
needs it the most is personal space
the most important thing for your sanity
yeah it may be
i'm not trying to yeah but let's talk
about that when you spend 50 60 years
taking care of everybody else
personal space having some time for you
is very important
absolutely before you lose in your mind
i i don't get the personal space thing i
don't get it
you can have personal space anywhere
yeah you can like go walk to the park
and just you know sit there
it's obvious i'm not saying it's not
important but i don't understand where
you need money for it
yeah yeah i started thinking that like
we're kind of doing the same thing that
they do like well you could just do this
if you need personal space but i mean
mental health is important but i imagine
as you get older like
you have more time alone because
everyone moves into their own lives
but maybe maybe not her situation i just
think
okay we're here to judge them that's
you're right you're right you're right i
i think the teeth lady makes more sense
right so everyone's problems here like
is very
in comparison to the other ones very
like minor things it feels like
yeah i need i need a new appliances mine
work
but i need more someone kicked in my
screen door
hey don't don't you my dog ain't my
teeth what
she needs a robot all right
i hope she wins safe it's never been so
obvious that
either the teeth lady or the charity guy
shouldn't get the money
share it again they're going to vote him
out yeah that's true
that's true okay what game do you have
um that smile that that was kind of
devilish
fortnite let's get it let's get the dub
he knew he had that ready guys
everyone whip out your smartphone we're
going to play snake
or get the most apples
you can think of a number whoever's
closest to your number is out
is that how you guys want to play it
okay sure the one who's farthest from my
number
is out yes it's your game and the number
is between what and why
i'll put 150 and let me think of a
special
number 150. special number let's do such
a grand dad
let me think about a special number for
you ken
think of a number 39 i'm locking in
38. excuse me how dare you
the number down so let's start with you
i'm gonna get the money again
31 seven eight
eight these are numbers between one and
fifty
i know forty-two can i just
that is a that's no you you say
forty-two spoken like an engineer it's
[ __ ] like an
engineer i mean you kind of reveal like
hey
these are all wrong and then the guy's
like oh a high number then
okay
and the engineer is out
got it this is incredible because the
number i
picked was the number of grandchildren i
have which is nine
oh that means you did you won
the price is right oh my god that bull
crap that they do
eight seven i should win and i'm
thinking you think i'm picking a number
between one and ten
i win but you don't win
i can win i win i win no
well you see here with the competition
watch who gets the
furthest away gets out no i win i
win give me the money special give me
the money
now give everybody one get everybody off
this couch i need a loan time get them
off the couch right now i
mean yeah did you think that was fair
did i think it was fair absolutely
i don't you agreed to do it right yeah
what do you mean
you can't go back and say people never
learn
anything you sound all they're saying
millennials
adults teenagers saviors
it never ends it's the same [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time
there's always somebody that says that
like no i didn't think it was fair but
it's usually the person that gets voted
off that's mad about it
yeah usually makes me lose hoping
humanity can't i'm not going to
hit that but she didn't think guest
number was fair
no because you hear that it's like an
echo of all of these they're all the
same
yeah you think they're be a group with
reason for once but
there's always like one or maybe two
people that are reasonable and the rest
are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's true i think it should be a
little more personal than putting a
number to guess okay
well say that before then next time
she's saying that because she's the one
that has like a legit like need
even though i'm pretty sure she has
teeth in her mouth right now i'm looking
at her like
oh zoom in on that side
that is definitely a bottom row of teeth
right there unless her lips are just
really shiny
do an ai uh quality improvement
in my video in hand and hands
holy [ __ ] she has teeth she borrowed
those from somebody
yeah what's the deal huh why did no one
say hey [ __ ] open your mouth what the
[ __ ] are those
[Music]
if you think she's like take some out
there's like like chewed dog marks all
over them or something
i'm like oh [ __ ] sorry that's [ __ ] up
there are actually teeth marks in them
teeth working your teeth oh my god
you chewed on them didn't you i think it
should be more personal
no it's a gamer the game it's a gang
again yeah
we're here to have fun we're here to
have fun
says the most mopey most negative person
in the group
and i also can't side note she her blue
sweater is like the most
ik ish blue shade i've ever seen and
it's really
it's distracting me so she's definitely
the real winner
maybe i have a thing for old ladies that
girl on the left is extra thick kaka you
know what i'm saying
i'm sorry mary i've been i've been
refraining myself from saying anything
but it was the first thing that i
thought that i saw
oh man she's a beautiful lady
that is some thick ass thighs right
there oh my god
she's got that uh striped skirt as well
like it really accentuates it
yeah i'm more of an ikea blue sweater
kind of guy but hey
to each his own we can judge each
other's personality we get
you know it's kind of a knowing thing
that's not a game i deserve it so
there you go that's the game i deserve
it more than you do
so there's that game so let me have it
let's go
let's find out uh okay most daring thing
oh and what does that help us with if
you haven't done anything daring then
you could
but who chooses if it's daring and then
yeah you could let them decide who
see there we go okay so you deserve the
money if you've lived like a hard life
that's what they're saying
that's interesting that's a different
okay perspective that we haven't heard
from the old people yeah let's get a
wild story here
all right and then let the two most that
the boring white dudes on the couch
mayonnaise is spicy i ran through a
wheat field once naked backwards
i think there was a politician in uk
that said that they were like what's the
wildest thing you've ever done she just
said like
i ran through a field of cows once
wow it's like what the [ __ ]
damn that's hard that's hard give her
the thousand dollars
i worked on the fishing boats in alaska
for five
seasons all right what have you done
probably the most daring thing
you make a ton of money doing that by
the way yeah
i should give the money to you then you
clearly don't spend money
well jumping out of an airplane um just
last year
i was i was thinking like you know she's
like flying through the air and just the
booty chicks just
just clapping
the whole way down
the mental image get it out
i don't really think anything daring i
think my most daring thing was to
give birth five times without any
anesthesia
scuba diving is one of the most daring
things i think i've done
are we voting off the most daring or the
least error the least
that really shows how much sense this
makes because it's not even obvious
what why they should get voted out right
who's the most boring person all right
get out
did you scuba dive i don't know i was
over 30 feet for sure
which was kind of risky four of them
were premeditated for themselves in that
position
and one of them was an impetuous sudden
thing
when the one that kicked the door down
okay which one of us is leaving
we've reached a conclusion here and
daring is the way we interpreted your
intent
the daring is choosing to do something
that was scary
and oh no jason the guy who kicked in
your back she's out back door lady out
and thoughtful engagement of something
daring
okay are you okay with that or do you
want to say anything else
i i don't know what i can say maybe the
guy had a gun
and i shouldn't have done it
i mean i'd be daring to chase someone
out right that's a bit daring i would
say that's
more daring than scuba diving now you
get to be on the fun couch
sorry about that well you guys what's
the matter with you
that's kind of cute that's kind of
wholesome they were all telling stories
is your way you ladies can make a little
room for me so i can sit down my back is
starting to kill me
who do you guys think will be the best
final three who are going to be the most
agreeable on one person me
[Laughter]
to me
uh i guess
it's just become a group thing now
hasn't it yeah we're staying
they've been on the couch together the
whole time and you know they got the
newcomer to the couch
and now that girls can get out of the
couch last on the couch leaves
if you're on disability you can get your
teeth replaced
if they're older no because i already
had dentures
so they can't replace my teeth for the
next three years
and they started they started the
picking apart it's all begin
all of your reasons sunk okay she'll get
some new teeth baby
she's this lady this lady just told her
and don't worry in three years you can
get you some more teeth until then
after you
don't worry just you can pay this off
in three years i don't understand why
you need this money now
really i mean there's no
hardly ever you hardly ever use your
teeth anyway decide who you're
eliminating
oh this is awkward i'm staying
i'm staying and you and you
and you y'all gotta decide
what voter off jenna
okay please jennifer jennifer yes there
are other resources out
[ __ ] chance dude bye jennifer pushed
her off the couch
yeah jennifer you dumb mitch okay
get your leopard flower shirt out of
here
i can't believe this she's pushing her
off yeah
she's ready to [ __ ] put her off the
couch get out of here and help you with
your teeth
okay so yeah she's just beating her up
and saying yeah yeah yeah
the two people that need a loan timer
like yeah yeah you don't need teeth it's
fine it's fine
three years we got you bro alone time
alone time [ __ ] alone time is sitting
here laughing
cute yeah i'm surprised you don't get a
long time i don't want to be [ __ ]
near you yeah
she probably gets plenty i mean i don't
understand yeah
[ __ ] is it happening jennifer has to sit
on the couch
is that just oh she's not leaving it's a
decision
someone's not saying anything girl come
on stick up we gotta go
jennifer you go ahead and we're gonna
all get your information because we all
have action at resources that can help
you oh
hey they did the mentor thing that we
know someone that can help you
um yeah don't worry about it they're
just going to refer to someone and it's
going to be the exact same what they
already been
quoted i googled some dentists in your
area and found it there you go
here you go here there's a google maps
you have a phone check it out
they wouldn't even offer the disabled
lady a c without her asking it's a shame
all right she had that uh well how was
that deciding
they share the money and go on vacation
oh this is a cute shot too
you're getting this this is cute where
are you gonna get a steal can you get a
steve yeah
did you think that was fair no
because i need something they want to go
on vacation i mean for once i agree
with that do you think it's fair no i
don't think that was fair they
definitely just mob mentality off and
then the girl on the right here she's
freaking wants appliances
you know so the other thing you want to
buy is this
ah i think it's about to get juicy
because they're all going to try to like
ikea blue they're going to try to get
her off and she's going to be like
oh it's all down for me you know this
saying respect the elders
yeah no no no after watching
this nah nah i don't think so not
anymore
what the [ __ ] is this respect the elders
they're much wiser oh
oh okay oh dude really did you ever have
like a thought when you're growing up
about when you thought like
adults knew what the hell was going on
in the world and then when you got older
you're like wow everyone's just an idiot
it was all a [ __ ] lie nobody knows
i bet my parents have no clue either
what the hell is happening
everyone's just pretending everyone's
been pretending this whole time ah
yes it's the biggest conspiracy that no
one talks about is that adults don't
know [ __ ]
no one knows anything do you guys expect
this to be the final three did you did
anybody picture this
i did no because i'm not in it
yeah they weren't needy they were just
wanting things you know
she's real mad about it oh man yeah i
like that
what i need or what i want is is being
placed so low
i've done a lot come through a lot been
through a lot going through a lot
i could use to go live some life
i don't think that's small i don't think
that's my new i think it's important
so i want to hear why each of the other
two think
the thousand dollars is important to you
again i suggest this for the final round
every time is everybody share
the one person they would vote to have
the thousand dollars
if it's not them i don't like that you
don't have to do that
she's like anything dude she literally
doesn't like anything
but herself clearly she wants that a
long time that's it justin because
you and i share a lot of the same
situations
i've never really been alone yeah always
had my kids
and other family members to take care of
and it's still going on you and i
share that wait a minute i've still got
kids to take care of us
yeah i still got family i'm still taking
care of people and i've never been
but you know the one difference the one
difference between them
and i is that they've all got to do
something
somewhere i want to go scuba diving you
are not going scuba diving
thank god she called her out on that
[ __ ] where were you going with that
you know how i'm different you're not
going scuba diving all right
can you even swim oh like what is it i'm
just checking baby
yes all right so she can swim at least
oh thank god i applied this girl i
actually i hope
she wins so much i will actually that
would redeem this video
but she played the fridge the lady on
the left like she she did all this
she said she went skydiving like last
year like she's got people that are
taking her to do things she doesn't need
alone time she has people that are doing
that for her so i don't know
wait ken are you saying that everyone
here is just talking a lot of [ __ ]
and
it doesn't what what
anything that would make it easier for
them to decide on the one person
i don't want to belittle the need for
personal space but
a need for a refrigerator and appliances
yes
there's a real at skull i think the
person i would have voted for sitting on
the couch
yeah yeah it's too late for for the need
thing to be
a choice anymore yeah the refrigerator
too
she's like oh yeah all right that's just
their opinion what the [ __ ] does alone
time mean
dude what is that i i love alone time
but i can get along time anywhere
at any time i see so many memes you know
the forever ever alone meme i think
people are nothing but alone these days
right
i i'm so confused by it she she doesn't
want to say that she want to go on a
holiday
because that doesn't sound as good right
i know that i would love personally like
i said it
isn't a need for space i just i need a
break
i would like to grieve i don't i don't
you know
what i would like to grieve without
having to support
somebody i feel like i'm going to
explode i just would like to go
somewhere so i can get it out and scream
it out
you don't need to go anywhere for
personal space i don't buy that argument
whatsoever i don't get it i think i mean
i guess they're mothers they have large
families and people are always around
them and
uh it's playing like the mental health
aspect of things which makes it hard to
argue about
and i don't know if you do that on
purpose or what i just don't see it like
literally just going outside to a park
for a day or something that's a lot of
personal space
compared to the what the other ones were
i don't i don't see it i don't agree uh
what are they going to go on vacation
there's not for mental health
it's like we have this inherent need
that we have to travel somewhere
well right in these ladies cases do you
think they're actually going to travel
by themselves like they're going to go
anywhere
yeah i don't buy that either but that's
a whole other thing but yeah it's
uh yeah for once i'm just like no that's
actually [ __ ]
i'm gonna recuse myself because i'm not
gonna
put all my stuff out there like that so
if y'all need that
i'll head out and enjoy that but i
expect somebody to call me up to go
enjoy that too
what if you're accusing yourself what
does the recuse mean
oh no i have no idea okay it's not just
me that hold up someone do with a cues
but you redo it i don't
disqualify oneself oh she's burning
herself off
i guess so so then y'all gotta see which
one of y'all's going upstairs
or do i get to say who i would say with
yes i say they split it was that an
option
if you guys all agreed to do that stop
it
stop no
no no
all right all right all right well at
least for once in this video
some respect for the woman in the middle
i will say that yeah
there's always somebody that does this
there's always someone in the end that's
like
just takes the elf just so they can like
move on they get tired yeah it seems
like that
yeah it seems like they just like
stopped caring after a while but uh yeah
fair enough to her props to her
but uh they're all [ __ ] pieces
you guys like those results yeah
that would come out like this how did
they come out
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] happened where am i
and you you you're not getting part of
that
i i i when you say split it i thought
you're going to be three ways
you know like i said i come from seven i
have seven
i know how to wait it'll come well god
bless you yeah that was nice
i respect that from her not not every
anyone else
it's just it's always so cringy to me
because the other two people are just
like
heck yeah gotta read it
[Music]
jennifer jennifer gotta go you just
gotta go
those ladies are so big about the woman
who lives on 12k a year and needs
to she clearly needed it the most yeah
yeah i think so too so her daughter made
a gofundme for her team that's nice oh
yeah nice
i assume that's already paid for at this
point but that's good to know
some things never change i guess i don't
know what to say
this yeah
[Music]
it's going to be you and i fighting in
the future seniors who are going to be
fighting over
it's up to me no shout to me
yeah maybe back in my
i always gave you video ideas you son of
a [ __ ] and you just
yeah well i always gave you a [ __ ]
shout out to you
what do you got [ __ ] do you upload that
video at
480p
your video quality is his ass is your
brain
[Laughter]
i wanted to see myself
ken check out ken check out the cut
subscribe to me
every subscriber i get i get one more
subscriber
so hit that subscribe and that's it bye
bye